اهلا سهام اهلا نادين كل عام وانتم بخير
والزملاء جميعا في مساء العربيه بخير نعم
فعلا سهام زيارات متتاليه من القاده في
السعوديه
للاماكن المقدسه اخر هذه الزيارات كان
ليولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الذي زار المسجد النبوي وعدى الصلاه في
الروضه الشريفه وتشرف بالسلام على رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وايضا صاحبيه
رضوان الله عليهما طبعا الامير محمد بن
سلمان ايضا زار لاحقا مسجد قباء وادى
ركعتي تحيه المسجد طبعا هذه الزياره
السهام ونادين تاتي تاكيدا على مدى اهتمام
القاده السعوديين والقياده في هذه البلاد
على الوقوف او على راحه الزوار والمصلين
في المسجد النبوي الشريف خاصه في شهر
رمضان الكريم الذي يزداد فيه عدد
المعتمرين بشكل كبير ومليون
للزياره وتاديه صلوات التراويح والتهجد
وطبعا السلطات السعوديه تولي العنايه
والاهتمام بالمدن السعوديه وتحديدا
الحرمين الشريفين خاصه في موسم العمره في
رمضان وموسم الحج وطيله ايام العام طيب
الحديث عن المعتمرين يا عبد الرحمن يعني
سابدا من حيث ختمت كلامك طبعا توافذ مستمر
للمعتمرين سواء من الداخل ومن خارج
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم كيف يتم
تنظيم هؤلاء المعتبرين نتحدث عن اكثر من
مليونين وثمانم
فعلا انادينا تم اصدار اكثر من مليونين
و800 الف تصريح صادره عن عبر تطبيقين
تطبيق نسك الكتروني وتطبيق توكلنا الان
العمره نادين وسهام بعد جائحه كورونا اصبح
لديها تنظيم مختلف للحرص على سلامه
المعتمرين وتنظيم الاعداد القادمه الى مكه
والمدينه المنوره طبعا مليونير الف عبرها
هذين التطبيقين خلال شهر رمضان او حتى قبل
تقريبا يوم واحد من اليوم طبعا يستمر
توافذ الزوار والمعتمرين عبر الرحلات
الجويه الداخليه والدوليه عبر مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي في جده البوابه الجويه
لمكه المكرمه ايضا مطار المدينه المنوره
ايضا السعوديه السلطات خصصت ايضا حافلات
خاصه في عدد من المواقف العامه في مكه
المكرمه لنقل المعتمرين الى المسجد الحرام
ذهابا وايابا بوقت لا يتجاوز عشره دقائق
عبر اكثر من تسع مواقف داخل المشاعر
المقدسه وخمسه مواقف خارج المشاعر المقدسه
ايضا من جهه اخرى تم تحديد من قبل وزاره
الحج والعمره عدد المرات التي يقوم بها
شخص باداء عمره وهي مره واحده خلال شهر
رمضان لاعطاء فرصه ايضا للجميع لاداء
العمره نعلم ايضا كثير من المواطنين
ومقيمين داخل السعوديه يريدون القيام
بمناسك العمره بالاضافه طبعا الى المسلمين
من كل انحاء العالم فلتنظيم هذه المساله
ندين السهام تم تحديد عمره واحده فقط في
شهر رمضان هي تحت الفرصه للجميع احنا
بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه التفاصيل
عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل مسائل عربيه من
عنيزه شكرا